savoir mais voilà pour essayer de
localiser voilà c'est tout j'essaie de
laisser la fota cette vitalité alors
sylvie tu te dis attention
alors je vous le dis si vous nous
rejoignez c'est la belle soeur de jean
gasc attend à dire que votre femme et la
soeur de s'est dit ému quand on rentre
dans la famille donc est ce que ça veut
dire
on va voir si les langues de bois parce
que vous n'êtes pas ce qu'ils disent à
sniper
ne pensez vous pas dit cela a choqué
parce qu'il ya un règlement ça me
rappelle soeur alors alors pas du tout
je peux pas l'avoir mais que ce soit
bien clair c'est sa vraie celle que je
m'adapte aux femmes
c'est la soeur de sa femme qui est
divine à comparer à elle mais j'ai le
j'ai le droit de dire que ma femme est
beaucoup plus belle que ça ça va je
crois que c'est dans le coeur doit aller
à l'épreuve sylvie aussi moi je moi je
trouve pas persuadé que ça va être un
horrible ans à l'époque des miss france
mais c'est vrai nos drôles mais on fait
la guerre dans les arènes il en mai au 5
juin
si tu nous regardes bonjour marc et une
palette jean-marc je prends ça pour un
héritage non non moi alors moi je
l'investis pas du tout mon intention
c'est en quoi il parle il s'est permis
de me juger chacun connaisse mais si ce
que je sais pas si je la connais pas
mais elle s'est permis de le juger si tu
veux ce qu'alex de suisse quand j'ai
rencontré sa soeur c'est qu'on n'est pas
bien de sortir avec quelqu'un de la télé
non j'ai dit je viens de contacter la
télé la fasse bouffer apparemment oui
c'est pas le débat mais sais-tu c'est
pour moi ça c'est pas c'est pas le
problème n'avait jamais rencontré votre
boxeur non mais sans précédent discute
avec elle m'apparaît me connaît très
bien
non mais bon je vais pourquoi mais là on
va la voir peut-être bientôt c'est la
ocz peut-être pas bien en place et les
missiles faut pas voir les niches en
l'air et comme je vais à la plage torse
nu sa c4
à peine le temps plein tout l'été on
s'est régalé à votre mariage
non non on va se marier je suis future
maman très bientôt mais elle va y ait ou
pas vous avez invité six et dix moi
personnellement je n'invite pas mais si
ma future femme de là j'étais bien sûr
elle vient le problème
y en a pas on ne sera pas assez je pense
élégant mais je trouve beaucoup vraiment
dommage que cette cette personne a des
missions étaient pour sa voix là parce
que c'est un règlement ok mais ya rien
de choquant je pense qu'il faudrait
remettre à niveau un petit peu les miss
et revenir un peu en 2021 ont déplu en
ouais je pense que c'est sylvie tellier
qu'il faut changer et on à anastasia
vrai que sylvie tellier et la
belle-soeur de lons basket c'est la
soeur de sa femme sur les api 1 c'est
tout et apparemment dont la famille est
une entente cordiale voudrait tous ces
minéraux pas la famille on a envie d'y
être
vous êtes invités madika alors vous qui
était en chine microbes vous connaissez
mieux le dossier que nous en fait ya un
règlement et sais pas si lui qui décide
c'est à la libre appréciation du comité
régional en fait s qui a dû se passer
pour cette jeune fille c'est que
peut-être elle a fait les photos il ya
longtemps
normalement où elle s'est présentée en
2020 elle n'a pas montré ses photos de
peur d'être disqualifié a menti c'est là
où l arraché des poteaux décliné dans sa
démarche parce que si elle est mon
d'entrée et quelques ce qu elle vaut
rien de choquant les photos on est bien
content que c'est de la faute de sylvie
tellier ou non à l'infraction la
réhabiliter le faire ces cas ne l'a pas
trop en fait ça serait ça serait le
désirent les gens qu'elle a nommé en
dessous et c'est pas possible parce que
ça va être l'anarchie parce qu'il ya
quand même trois comme s'il y avait eu
cette histoire surtout en guadeloupe où
c'est avec cette jolie et très jolie ou
en plus c'était pour une cause que
l'association des banques fait que match
en retard du sens et je sais que ça là
ça la dérange et je sais que le
règlement il en train d'évoluer à des
réflexions
alors les avec certitude